hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor and on this
week's video we're gonna do a QA
now last week on Sunday at 7 p.m. I put
a video out and had a lot of people
asking questions about property so on
this video here's I'm gonna do two
things firstly is I'm gonna answer some
questions from last week but secondly is
I want you right now during this video
while you're watching to post your
comments and questions if you've got
niggling property questions whatever we
might be if it's around business
structure tax deal sourcing Lease Option
agreements rent to rents how to raise
finance HMOs how to find a buyer to let
property have a structured finance set
mortgages anything like that comment
below
even is just how do I get started
anything at all comment below and I will
be answering your questions next week on
Sunday at 7 p.m. so don't forget to
subscribe
turn the notification about arm so that
you don't miss me answering your
question next week and also please do me
a massive favour and smash that like
button that would be awesome send the
love so what have we got so rou how mir
says is it worth buying from an auction
and selling on it's impossible for me to
just say yes or no it depends on what
you're buying so buying a property from
an auction buying it from the estate
agent buying it from a vendor direct it
doesn't matter where you're buying it
from what matters is the property itself
is it a good deal or not pros and cons
to buying from auction the pros are
often if you buy from an auction
properties are cheap they've often got
problems with them which means that you
can then fix that problem and push the
value up also the good thing about
buying from an auction is that once you
put your offer in and it's been accepted
and you win the bed they can't pull out
but you can't pull out either but it's
just fast no messing around I've bought
from auction and many times I've also
not bought from auction I bought through
agents of what through direct to vendors
so should you buy a property from an
auction and then sell it on yeah do it
100% just make sure that you when you're
buying a property you've done the
surveys on it beforehand before you even
go to the auction you viewed the
property make sure that you can afford
to buy it here's the thing how much is
it going to cost to do the property up
and how much is that gonna lift the
value of the property if the property if
you get it for a hundred grand and then
you spend 20 grand on it and then the
value is 120 or you gonna buy for a
hundred spend 20 on it then sell it for
120 you've made nothing in fact you're
now at minus because you paid for the
fee
and the solicitors didn't make any sense
so you've got to make sure that for
every pound you spend your adding two
pounds worth of value to the property
and to do that you need to know what's
the refurb costs going to be and what's
the end value going to be so just make
sure you get educated you work out how
to get the figures but auction is a
thumbs up from me if you do it right
what else we got it's on nearly teens I
hope I pronounced that right we're
looking at a B&B property and turning it
into an HMO is this a good strategy
we're semi-retired and don't want the
headache that goes with a B&B
is it good strategy a B&B might be a
headache but HMO also might be a
headache so to be honest tenants
full-stop are gonna require work and
management the difference between a HMO
and a single that is instead of having
one tenant you've suddenly got four five
six tenants it does require management
and work so it's all about the the power
team side of it and the systemization of
it a B&B property as long as you've got
it managed properly you've got a team
that are running it that could
potentially be totally seamless and no
headache same with a HMO if you do it
right and you have a power team in place
then that could also be seamless if you
haven't got a power team and you
interview it yourself whether it's a
single layer or lots of single that's
whether it's a HMO service accommodation
air B&B B&B it could end up being a
headache so if you want to do as a HMO
make sure that you've got good HMO
management companies in the area how do
you find a chomo management companies
Google go on spare room type code at UK
and look for properties that are
currently being rented by the room and
then look at the agents the agents phone
numbers call them up but definitely
don't use a high street management
company to manage an HMO and also
definitely if you want them easy life
and you're semi-retired don't manage it
yourself
hope that helps thank you for the
question Elena Weaver says could you
interview students of yours who are
doing female room shares I could do I do
have students that do female only room
shares by all means I can bring them on
I think what they'd probably tell you is
that the disadvantage to doing female
only and there's a big disadvantage is
you've suddenly killed 50 percent at
least of your market of your potential
tenants but the good thing is some
females they do like lady only
hmos lady anyhow shares so anyone who
wants a lady only house share will
suddenly be really attracted to your ad
so I think it does work pretty well
I know leer and Cheryl Miller I know
they've they've they've successfully
done female-only
how shares you can check up their story
maybe we'll put a little link just now
but the head you can check out and see
their story feel free to get in touch
with them I hope that helps guns gaming
other Hong Kong's gaming asked questions
every week doing this is like free
one-on-one mentoring that you get just
from YouTube how awesome is that
when doing went to serviced
accommodation went to essay you talk
about corporate let agreements but isn't
that only if you're going to let your
employees stay there and shouldn't I
that don't have a company user
management agreement just set up a
company dude cost like seventeen pounds
you set up a company on Companies House
seventeen pounds within 24 hours
use a corporate let agreement and it
doesn't matter that your employees
aren't going to be staying there they
don't need to be your employees all it
is is if a company is renting an
apartment that means that you've got a
management agreement the corporate let
then you can put guests in the property
without it being subletting whereas if
you yourself have an individual st
contract I think my advice third GoM's
gaming would we do just be upfront with
the agent and just say look this is it's
gonna be in the house this is who's
going to be there sometimes even the
agent will give you the contracts and
the paperwork to use why not be the
financial freedom challenge I was
stripped from everything and I had no
money I had no contract so I had no
connections I had to start all over
again from scratch I just went into an
estate agent say I've secured a rental
serviced accommodation deal I told them
my situation they provided me with the
agreement and if you haven't seen the
video of me doing this again we're gonna
put up a little link right above my head
just click on the little link or the
icon and you can watch the video of me
starting again from scratch so that's my
advice to you syndra I'm from Norway
when digging your stuff would you
recommend going to the crash course
given this probably based on the market
need and this did same story Joel Joel
hack and so on hope I'm pronouncing
these right I'm from Sweden and I'm very
interested in flying over 20 new crash
courses and start my journey as a
property investor is it possible we
brakes it 1 billion percent and the
crash courses are selling out like
they've never saw before so again I'll
put a link in the description the crash
caused by the way for anyone that
doesn't know it's a two day training
program where you learn to become a
property investor
all the formulas and what it takes to
learn how to make money in property even
if you're starting from zero and tickets
are on the house from me to you
completely free of charge listen man I
really enjoy doing these I'm going to be
committed to doing a video like this
every single week next Sunday at 7 p.m.
I'll be answering your questions which
are on this video so comment any
questions below all we know I'll take
them and answer them for the next Sunday
video also friendly doesn't know I
personally film and put out a new
property investment video every single
day that's how crazy obsessed I am with
teaching content and just sharing the
knowledge that I've got why do I do it I
think I do it because number one it
keeps me fresh number two I really enjoy
doing it and I get a kick out of seeing
people become successful number three is
I am sad and have no friends no number
three is just because what I'm going to
understand agency people know who I am
everyone in this space in the property
world knows who I am why probably
because I keep putting videos out on
YouTube and that really helps me as a
business person
how can people do business with you if
they don't know who you are so I love to
just share the message and tell people
who I am
so I'd really appreciate it if you did
share the video share the channel tell
your friends tell your home is sometimes
just really awkward because you people
come to a crash course and they're there
in secret and then they see next row one
of their best friends and they're like
I'm going to show you oh my gosh oh yeah
oh there's my mom on the front row like
just call your friends financial freedom
is for anyone anybody can be financially
free when they learn how to invest
successfully in property even starting
with no money I really believe that from
the bottom of my heart so if you have
questions comment below if you want to
be trained by myself or my top trainers
in the UK to be a property investor and
book on the property investors crash
course link in the description thanks so
much for watching over and out
[Music]